sudáfrica sufre las consecuencias cada
vez más agresivas de la crisis climática
las inundaciones provocadas por las
lluvias torrenciales en la provincia de
kwazulu-natal en la costa este del país
han causado devastación a su paso y
provocado la muerte de cientos de
personas
cuando llegue pregunte dónde estaban mis
hijos no estaba ni preocupada por mi
casa que se la había llevado al agua
pregunté dónde estaban mis hijos porque
les dije que se fueran con mi hermana
nadie me respondió así que pregunté a
uno de mis hijos y él tampoco lo sabía
así que me di cuenta que se los había
llevado el agua para hacer frente a los
daños materiales como la destrucción de
plantas generadoras de electricidad
carreteras y edificaciones las
autoridades han desbloqueado un fondo de
emergencia de 60 y 83 millones de
dólares aunque las autoridades locales
de durban estiman que las pérdidas
ascienden a miles de millones y que
cerca de 40 mil personas se han visto
afectadas por las lluvias torrenciales
las inundaciones me han afectado mucho
como puedes ver estoy cavando un baño no
tengo baño no tengo agua no tengo
electricidad ni tengo comida en la casa
todo se ha ido con estas inundaciones
mientras se espera que las lluvias
continúen este fin de semana la
comunidad científica alerta que el
calentamiento del océano índico debido a
las emisiones de efecto invernadero
provocará cada vez más y mayores
tormentas e inundaciones sobre todo en
la costa del país por lo que piden a las
autoridades sudafricanas aumentar la
inversión en infraestructuras y
políticas ambientales para prevenir
futuras catástrofes